elle s'est imposée comme un des sujets
majeurs dans les foyers français
l'inflation le phénomène inquiète mais
ce matin bonne nouvelle le gouverneur de
la Banque de France vient apporter une
dose d'espoir alors je dis très
clairement à votre micro ce matin que
nous allons ramener l'inflation vers 2%
qui est notre objectif d'ici fin 2024
afin 2025 je veux être clair marcovel
c'est pas seulement une prévision que
nous faisons c'est un engagement que
nous prenons vis-à-vis des français
actuellement de 6,2% sur le mois de
février
l'inflation devrait donc passer à
environ 3% en fin d'année une baisse et
des conséquences positives sur
l'alimentaire alors que les prix flammes
dans les rayons ils devraient eux aussi
connaître un retour en arrière mais il
va falloir s'armer de patience quand
tous les prix augmentent il faut pouvoir
tout comparer alors là il est carrément
dans la guerre comparative puisque il
montre que le Clair serait le moins cher
et puis ensuite il y a Lidl Super U
Intermarché puis alors on tourne la page
et là on tombe sur une pleine page de
chez vous une part page Intermarché
grâce à nos marques les Français feront
peut-être moins de sacrifices et les
tout derniers chiffres du Conseil
mondial de l'or indique que les Français
ont acheté exactement pour 5,6 tonnes de
pièces et de lingot c'est un chiffre que
l'on n'avait pas vu depuis 2011 2011
c'était l'année où la crise en Grèce
avait fait craindre à certains une
défaillance des banques et donc où les
épargnants s'étaient rués sur l'or pour
mettre leurs économies en sécurité et
puis pourquoi le gouvernement s'en mêle
si vous dites c'est la concurrence vous
laissez faire et puis des gens
choisissent parce que le gouvernement
doit donner l'impression de faire tout
contre l'inflation qui est le mal des
français alors que l'inflation aux yeux
du gouvernement a deux vertus quand les
Français ont des soucis de pouvoir
d'achat ils ne font pas la grève est-ce
qu'ils ont besoin de chaque centime de
revenus et en plus ça les désendette
quand ils ont emprunté à des taux plus
bas on est allé avec Michel Édouard
Leclerc avec Alexandre Bompard on était
pour le coup uni on avait appelé ça
pendant le covid consacrer et
effectivement
on aurait eu 50 produits et nous
notamment chez Intermarché Neto on pense
que 50 produits c'est trop restrictif le
Sénat a adopté l'article 7 ce texte
prévoit de reporter l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
c'est la droite et la majorité
présidentielle qui ont permis son
adoption sur 345 votants 200 ont voté
pour 115 contre un vote largement porté
par des députés les républicains de
l'inflation mais le ministre Olivier du
socle se garde bien de nous remercier
que les députés de droite je vous
remercie tous les sénateurs qui ont voté
il est dessinateurs républicains c'est
vrai sénateur centriste et sénateurs de
la majorité présidentielle soyons
sérieux on savait qu'à un moment donné
l'article 7 serait voté au Sénat je
pense qu'on a essayé de retarder autant
qu'on pouvait je l'assume le vote de cet
article 7 mais il devait il était
probable qu'il serait voté un moment
donné ne prenez pas les français pour
des oiseaux et respecter l'institution
la grande institution du Sénat j'ai été
élu Benjamin cette maison en 95 mes
chers amis
oui et ben je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais
vu je n'ai jamais vu je n'ai jamais vu
une opposition se comporter comme ça
l'obstruction c'est le Parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri est-ce que la démocratie
française n'est pas suffisamment malade
pour une fois de plus lui enfoncer la
tête un peu plus sous l'eau et moi je
mets en garde mes collègues de gauche je
vois bien qu'il y a la tentation d'une
mélenchonisation moi je ne veux pas que
le Sénat se mélange vous êtes en train
de vous
[Applaudissements]
dire le Sénat
processus parlementaire va éteindre ou
galvaniser la ruche pour l'instant ça ne
va pas l'éteindre mais une fois que la
loi sera adoptée si elle l'est et ça
sera dimanche soir là peut-être qu'une
un certain nombre de Français on le sait
qui sont fatalistes qui estiment que
c'est toi de toute façon passera et sera
appliqué décideront de rentrer dans le
chez eux plutôt que de manifester
aujourd'hui il faut passer à autre chose
puisque le gouvernement nous entend
toujours pas malgré 3 millions et demi
de manifestants dans les rues un barrage
finalement levé dans le calme par les
gendarmes en milieu de matinée on la
voit à l'antenne cette lettre au
président de la République vous et votre
gouvernement restez silencieux devant
l'expression de ce puissant mouvement
social dans l'urgence de ce moment et la
gravité de ses conséquences les
organisations syndicales constituent
l'insert syndicale exprime ensemble la
demande de vous rencontrer et Florent
Bergier de la CFDT l'a souvent répété il
a dit que si le gouvernement n'écoutait
pas des manifestations qui étaient
paisibles alors ça dégénérait cette
absence de réponse constitue un grave
problème démocratique il conduit il
manquablement à une situation qui
pourrait devenir explosive je pense
qu'on gagne du temps à ne pas trop
écouter ce que dit la France insoumise
ce qu'ils ont perdu leur boussole
démocratique le président de la
République a été élu par le peuple
français il a toutes légitimité pour
faire adopter le texte de la réforme des
retraites 82 des Français assurent être
en colère contre la politique économique
et sociale du gouvernement 51% d'entre
eux se disent très en colère lorsque 31%
le sont un peu au bout du compte une loi
est adoptée par les représentants du
peuple français ça s'appelle la
démocratie